hello today's video is about clinical
usage of antibody or therapeutic usage
of antibodies in that I will talk about
Herceptin Herceptin is one of the good
treatments for her2 positive breast
cancer Herceptin is actually a antibody
known as trust to the map in this video
I would describe the immunological
mechanisms by which her to acts upon the
breast cancer and how the treatment
works so the incident of breast cancer
is increasing day by day and if the
growth rate of bread can spread trans
cancer is like that
so statistician predict that almost
forty seven female would be diagnosed
with breast cancer in around 2020 now if
we talk about u.s. population every one
in eight woman is affected by breast
cancer or is in a high risk of getting
affected by the breast cancer so breast
cancer is increasing day by day and who
published a map of the most risk zone
where breast cancer is prevalent a huge
amount of US population Australia and a
large part of Asia and Europe is
affected by this kind of increased risk
of breast cancer so normal breast cell
for its normal growth and development
and division has a receptor known as
human epidermal growth factor receptor
or heart so her has different families
har one heart to heart three etc etc one
of them is heart to heart to receptors
are present on the normal cells then
about 20,000 in number in a normal press
cell but in case of a breast cancer
which is hard to positive the number of
heart to receptor on the cell surface
increases dramatically this cancer could
also occur due to a duplication in the
heart to team which is erbb2
now we would look at the mechanism in
detail so here it how works so hard - is
a receptor present on the membrane of
the cell surface and it's a epidermal
growth factor receptor so whenever
growth factor binds to it the receptor
internal cytoplasmic domain gets
phosphorylated now the phosphorylated
receptor is talking site per several
molecules
one example is g RB 2 which is growth
factor binding of protein - now g RB 2
or pi 3 kinase get activated with the
phosphorylated receptor now pi3k can
actually trigger the signaling cascade
which is known as indoor pathway now
mTOR pathway is one of the most
important truth pathways in the body now
mTOR pathway ultimately would activate
the molecular players which regulate
translation it would ultimately help in
the anabolic processes or growth another
bona fide pathway for growth and
development and and division of the
cells in the body is map kinase pathway
now this activated receptor can
ultimately activate the signaling
cascade of map kinase pathway and map
kinase pathway develops multiple gene
including cyclin d1 which helps in cell
division and thereby cellular
proliferation also other Pro up of other
anti-apoptotic jeans like bcl2 bcl-xl is
the downstream product of this map
kinase pathway so thereby normally this
pathway in a breast cell allow that the
pressure would develop normally and
proliferate but what happens in the
cancer in the breast cancer is the
number of receptors on the cell surface
dramatically increase from 20,000 to
about 22 million now it could occur due
to increased
transcription from that gene or it could
occur due to increased transport of the
receptor or maybe the receptor is so
stable that in
doesn't get turned over in a normal rate
so whatever may be the reason the
surface expression of the receptor
dramatically increases the cell surface
expresses a huge amount of receptor as a
result huge amount of signaling is
happening through the through these
receptor so emptor pathway and map
kinase pathways output is increasing
several hundred folds which ultimately
leads to uncontrolled growth pathway
even if these pathways an important
growth regulator pathway in normal cases
but these pathways when goes wrong or
when are hyperactivated result in
uncontrolled growth now the treatment of
these is Herceptin which is a antibody
which binds to these hard two receptors
now Herceptin binds to the hard two
receptors and interfere with the
signaling processes so the signaling now
becomes weakened and the output of the
signal is less so uncontrolled growth is
kind of prohibited now not only it
interferes with signaling it does
another important thing which is kind of
very intuitive so many of the cells in
the immune system has MC receptor which
is targeted against the FC region of
this antibody one on one such cell is
natural killer cell which are the super
duper killers in the immune system so
the NK cells are like specific specific
bombard airstrikes so what happens is
here are some soldiers who looked at
some enemy vehicles so one of the one of
the option what they can do is directly
attack but what they do intellect
intellectually they send out the
coordinates and bring about a airstrike
which allow the destruction of the enemy
vehicles it's a clever strategy now the
NK cells are actually the bomber planes
so here the antibodies are marking the
territory or marking the particular
coordinates
which of which tumor cell to be
destructed so NK cell quickly bind to
that antibody by its FC receptor and NK
cell secretes secretory granules filled
up with granzymes and porphyrins and
thereby this tumor cell undergoes
apoptosis or programmed cell death that
is how trust to the map or Herceptin
kills a breast cancer cell now not only
trust you to map their other antibodies
as well which could be used as
therapeutics for example we took Zima
which is also used for several types of
cancer and autoimmune diseases
another is O'Malley's meth oh man using
map is and B inflammatory molecule which
binds to the FC region of IgE antibody
and prevent the IgE antibody to point to
mast cell and D granulate D granulating
of the Marcelle and thereby save the
body from hyper hyper active
inflammatory responses so this is how
antibody could be used in the field of
medicine for several therapeutic and
several treatments I hope you enjoyed
this video if you liked my video give it
a thumbs up you can help me by sharing
this video among your friends and please
subscribe to my channel thank you for
listening